which is going off from what i was
saying before where i feel like it's
just harder to
consume media now because just less
things stand out and there's
so much choice that sometimes you have
you have to get that point where
you're like you want you sit down you
have like your lunch or something you're
like oh let's let's put it
let's put something on a lunch and then
you spend like [ __ ] 15 minutes
scrolling down your [ __ ] anime list
or your netflix or something
and then you end up finishing your lunch
by the time you like finish scrolling
down and looking at everything
yeah you know yeah i just i just clicked
the first thing into my youtube
recommender
it's half decent really yeah because i'm
like i
i can't if i know i'm going to be eating
like i can't put netflix on because i
know i'm going to eat the food with
before the credits even [ __ ] finish
yeah yeah
yeah i always have to put on youtube but
like for me it's like it's the opposite
i put on
i put on a video that where i'm like
okay yeah i can re-watch that
right it's usually a video that i know i
enjoyed and i know i liked but has the
replayability that i can watch it again
during lunch
so weirdly enough i don't actually go
out and like look for new videos
during like a lunch break or something
yeah like i need to be like in that mood
of like
discovery right this way that sounds but
before i go to bed the amount of times
i've opened netflix and i had
luck and just like well all of these
seemed like i'd probably have fun but
[ __ ] i mean i don't know i guess i'll
put report of the week on them watching
me
i don't know like yeah exactly here's a
question for you for you though connor
you said you're like you watch way less
anime now than you used to
would you say that maybe you you might
be growing out of it in any sense of the
world
like it just doesn't fit your lifestyle
anymore you're maturing out of anime
yeah
no i mean i still love anime yeah yeah i
like the banger shows but i think i've
just
i don't know stop [ __ ] lying to
myself like i think because of the
i think this is the position i was in i
felt indebted to anime like i had to
watch it
right yeah you know back when i first
started i was like i'm an anime youtuber
and you have to watch it
keep up with it you know so i can be
like i can keep up with the hot takes
yeah but i think you know maybe like two
three years ago i just kind of realized
like i don't like doing this
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna watch the
biggest shows that come out and enjoy
them and have a great time yeah yeah
i've anime right the way i can
like you don't care to like go out and
like discover if the show is good alone
right no i have no
no no ambition to do yeah i'll just wait
until everyone agrees a show is good
yeah i'll watch it because i know the
show is going to be good like
i i've had so many experiences where
i've just watched an anime that's so
[ __ ] boring that i'm like
okay i mean yeah i guess i guess
decadence was fine
you know did you watch decadence i was
like three episodes the decadence
because everyone was hyping it up yeah
everyone was hyping it up is it good
i i totally agree with you it's just
like there's so many shows now
like nowadays which is seasonal anime
and i feel like people only hype it up
because
it's a seasonal anime and there's
nothing else to talk about so someone's
got to hype up
something i mean it's really telling
because 90 of those shows that get hyped
up while it's airing you don't hear
about it after it's finished
i i also just watch a lot more youtube
like i think on average i watch like 40
hours a week
i agree yeah i watch a lot more youtube
there's a lot of youtube yeah
the thing is right okay youtube tells me
because you can actually look on the app
and it can actually tell you how much
youtube you watch a week yeah
and it'll tell you how much you watch an
average day and it's like four hours a
day or watch or something
on average at least yeah but like i mean
like i said 40 i mean i'm probably the
same i just haven't checked
the problem is right is that it's not
wait it's on the youtube app yeah it's
on youtube
i'm like it's like deep in the settings
i'll look while i'm explaining it but i
i remember that there was uh
um because essentially right when i'm i
go to the gym right for two hours
because i have youtube premium so you
can you can lock your phone and listen
to audio
yeah i watch youtube videos are just
audio only so that's like two hours when
i take a [ __ ] you bet i'm putting the
youtube video on for two minutes
when i'm brushing my teeth youtube video
when i'm in the bath youtube video when
i'm working and it's not important i
don't need to listen youtube video yeah
i have four and a half hours daily
watch four hours no i've apparently
already just today watched three hours
i mean i know that i watch
what if i don't look i don't have to
know
dude on sunday i watched eight hours of
youtube geez i don't even remember doing
that no because here's the thing why
like i've watched 50 hours in the last
week
yeah because here's the thing about
youtube is that it's just content on
youtube is just that much
easier to consume right yeah because you
know when you
you have like a kind of like a
subconscious value system when it comes
to like content so when you watch like a
netflix show or something it's like a
you're sitting down and you're paying
the [ __ ] attention right but when it's a
youtube video you could do
be doing whatever and you just can have
it on the in the background
and just you know and just and just not
really give a [ __ ] about it you know
yeah i also like keeping up with youtube
a lot like i think i'm way more invested
in like
youtube like as a subculture yeah than
than
anime honestly like i'm like i i've
been following youtube like religiously
for like seven years yeah i know all
like the drama everything that's ever
happened on youtube i'm sure like if we
did a quiz
i'm sure it aced that quiz yeah are you
a youtube fan i'm a big youtube fan
no i i know exactly what you mean
because it's it's exactly the same in
like every
subculture of youtube as well because
like i know a lot of vanity tubers
who i swear spend most of their time
watching other annie cheapers
as opposed to watching anime and i feel
like i feel like every attitude has been
through that stage
when you find yourself watching more
annie tubes
than you do watching anime yeah yeah
yeah it's like i could watch this anime
or i could watch this anna trooper
talking about that anime exactly
and now it's just grown from my watch
other anitus to now i just watch
other youtubers in general yeah rather
than like my anime consumption has
remained the same this entire time
but my consumption of like watching
other anime youtubers and watching other
youtubers has just grown immensely
yeah and that's why i feel like it's
it's so weird
when i see when i whenever i see the
comments and you know the comment i'm
talking about where it's like
oh i'm having trouble keeping up with an
anime but a two hour trash taste episode
give me give me that [ __ ] any day of the
weekend or whatever yeah yeah i guess
because it's easy to digest right i
think with anime i mean
joey can't relate but you know there's
subtitles i got a [ __ ] focus you know
it's like all right okay fine i guess
i'll pitch well i mean i have to focus
on listening
i guess that's true true yeah but i
still yeah i mean
i don't know i guess it's sad because i
just don't want to admit that i've
fallen out of anime
really i think that's the saddest part
right especially because you've
like followed it for all this time right
like yeah i guess it's kind of sad being
like i guess i'm just not into anime as
much as i used to be
like i don't know do you think that
that's consistent that's just part of
growing up
yes it is but do you think as well that
it might have to do with the fact that
you have grown up or is it the fact
of like just the quality of the shows or
like the types of
yeah the anime is better now than it was
but did you feel like maybe it's just
you enjoy different kinds of media now
because
let's let's remove anime from the
equation but what's like the last tv
show you probably probably enjoyed
anime or not
great pretender okay okay and that was
like
that's an anime and yeah it was like two
three months ago yeah right right what
the [ __ ] about him watching
youtube apparently because cause cause
he here's what i've realized where
you know when when i find a show that i
really enjoy
it's so rare nowadays because we consume
so much media but so much of it it's
just [ __ ] forgettable yeah
and that's why you like you you do watch
a lot of youtube
right but is that the same kind of
enjoyment that you get from watching
some of your favorite shows
that you know you remember from as a kid
or you know when you're marathoning and
showing you're just really really into
it
and i feel like just because we can see
more media doesn't necessarily mean that
we
value media the same it's just it's just
i feel like we
we've just programmed our brain to never
have dead space so we're always
consuming something
yeah and i guess because of the age of
the internet and you know having
being more knowledgeable about anime
especially in our position right yeah
almost commodified so
yeah i guess it's kind of weird because
it's i think my motivations for wanting
your channel an hour to just feel in the
loop
right yeah not because i actually want
to watch that show yeah which is why
i've just fully admitted to myself i'm
just only going to watch the big shows
everyone agrees that's the thing right
it's like it definitely doesn't help
when
everyone else around you was like hey
have you watched this show have you
watched this show have you watched this
yeah what are your thoughts on this show
because because
to us is different now because to us
it's like anime has become a job and
someone who watches as much anime as me
like i can
i can see a show and i can be like i can
see that this is a good show you know
what i mean
i can break it down to be like yeah i
know why i know why this is a good show
i know why
i know why people are hyping this up but
when when you when you've reached a
point where you just it
you kind of become part of the seasonal
cycle you kind of see like
the you kind of see the patterns you
know there's there's there's always
these the same i'm just turning it into
a [ __ ] conveyor belt
i i had that exact experience when i
went to go watch the demon slayer movie
yeah i was like i took
one look at the poster and i was like i
know exactly what's gonna happen
yeah yeah exactly right like just just
from like oh yeah this character's gonna
do this and this character's gonna do
this and sure enough i was like
90 correct on what happened yeah and
like is that a good thing
or i mean i still enjoyed it but it's
like you know the whole like
wow factor was completely gone right and
i think that's the entire reason why
i've
kind of been burnt out on anime and i've
been much more into manga
because like nowadays especially
nowadays
everybody is talking about every anime
that matters
yeah right it's almost like inescapable
yeah but the manga side of things
because like ninety percent of manga had
don't have translations
it's still a mystery yeah right it's
what the anime
community was you know it's like like 10
10 years ago i totally agree and that's
why like i i
love going into the world of manga
because you don't in anime you don't get
that feeling of discovering that hidden
gem anymore there's there's no feeling
of discovery because everyone knows what
everything good is
you know what's going to come out three
seasons there's no there's no surprise
anymore
like even when there's a good show that
i can recommend someone watching the
season
to me i'm just like i can tell this is a
good show and i can tell people would
enjoy it yeah but i don't enjoy in the
same kind of like
wow this is this is like this is
something new to me
i'm like okay this is just a very solid
show this season and i
recommend people watch it if they want
to experience x kind of thing but
when i go into manga i'm just like i
don't know what's going to be good i
know
i don't know what's going to be bad the
amount of times i've like finished
reading a manga series and i've said to
myself how is no one talking about this
yeah is way more than any amount of
anime that i've ever covered
because again like that whole mystery of
well it's an event right as well like
it's
you know it's coming out this season
it's one of the things right yeah you're
watching weekly right like it's
it's gonna end like manga is so ongoing
that it's hard to
yeah i think have that kind of hype for
it right yeah and there's there's like
way more i feel like there's way more
choice with manga as well and it's it's
such a such a vast world
[ __ ] loads yeah that i don't feel
like anyone's going to be able to you
know read
everything so challenging
this is literally like you said first
world problems the podcast yeah
my toilet seat temperature is one
celsius
what can i say i'm dead no i mean it
totally is but
i mean it's it's totally i feel like a
problem that has come with this new
generation where there's just
so much to do so much to watch it's
impossible too much to do
it's too much it's like that whole
[ __ ] meme of like you know white
people re-watching the office for like
the tenth time yeah
just like that's funny you know
like i've rewatched uh always sunny in
philadelphia more times than i can
[ __ ] count
amazing yeah it's fun
like because there's so much we've
desensitized ourselves to so much as
well and
like i you know i i look at someone like
you who probably watches more content
more media than you ever have in your
life yeah probably but
thinking back about what's actually
memorable you you it's like
right i like you i think you you were
like what the [ __ ] like when i play
league of legends or play games i watch
youtube videos on the other
like screen yeah i can't do that yeah i
can't do that you can't
it's the same as people who can you know
watch a tv show while reading a book
it's like how do you do well that's
[ __ ] up
yeah right it's like how do you do that
because like listening to music while
reading a book i can't even do that i
can do that
i can't do it okay here here's a
question do you remember the first time
you watched a youtube video at 1.5 or
two times speed
no i've never done it have you ever done
that of course yeah yeah i've never done
that and i realized
because i realized why would i ever want
this that just means i'm not enjoying
the content
how it's supposed to be like enjoyed and
then i realized wait i could
just consume this content in a faster
in in in like in like a shorter time
period and then there are people who are
life hacks legit watch every video
yeah two times and then i've realized
like i realized it was like a habit like
that was subconsciously forming and then
i realized
wait i'm not even [ __ ] enjoying this
content anymore i'm just i just
literally i'm just watching it just to
keep up and i'm like all right wait
that's that's
that's pretty [ __ ] because that's
that's that's kind of like hacking my
mind into
what [ __ ] entertainment is at the end
of the day right you know you know what
i mean i do think it's like slowly
turning into like an
infowars what is entertainment
are we consuming too much media